let's go back to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 we'll go to our next caller from
the 2 3 9 area code caller and 2 3 9
tell us your name where you're calling
from and what's on your mind today
what's up David my name is Noah I'm from
South Florida got it what's on your mind
today and I just wanted to ask you about
your opinion on specifically political
discourse between citizens in this
country because it seems we're at a time
now where there's a really large amount
of people that have been specifically
misinformed either to help someone's
bottom line or to help them get
reelected and you can't even have a
conversation with these people when
you're both reaching from different
pools of facts yep
so if violence isn't the answer and
you're supposed to converse with them to
try to change their mind but they won't
even listen to the facts you're
presenting how do you have a
conversation yeah what other option is
there between that you know so I have
two answers on this one is the
idealistic answer which is we should
find ways to be able to get beyond our
differences and have productive
conversations where we can come to some
kind of agreement on what is best for
the majority of the United States and
the people blah blah blah right you can
already tell it's BS your eyes are
already glazing over Noah because this
is not going to happen and so well yeah
my eyes are glazing over because I'm
looking at your YouTube channel right
now and one of the titles of your videos
is me and this libertarian can't even
agree on economics exactly and so that's
where I get to sort of the more
pragmatic reality and I've said this
before from an from a voting standpoint
if you are opposed to the current
administration don't waste your time
trying to change the mind of the
ideologically committed trumpets that
remain the amount of time you would need
to maybe change one Trump voters mind
you might be able to sign up five or ten
people who didn't vote last time and the
voter turnout alone yeah
could have flipped the election so you
know I deal with this in Argentina as
well I was just in Argentina visiting my
family and politics has become so toxic
there that at most family gatherings my
family is basically centre left and very
left right like there's really no right
wingers in my family and still because
of the way in which politics has become
so toxic my family just does not talk
about politics there's usually
agreements at the beginning of every
every gathering not to talk about
politics and it's not that different in
many parts of the United States here
where you have different views so my I'm
gonna focus on pragmatics here with you
Noah and I would say don't even bother
just try to get more people to vote hey
thank you very much David I love
everything you do alright appreciate it
South Florida great to hear from South
Florida